das hier geht an dieter bohlen er hat
für eure sendung die wahrscheinlich
millionen leute im fernsehen sehen ein
clip in dem ich vorkommen wenn leute als
youtube hat man es nicht immer leicht
ich weiß es schwer zu glauben wenn man
hier sieht die mit ihren supersportwagen
rom prall mit ihren kranken wohnungen
mit ihren ultra teuren uhren aber es ist
wirklich so das leben weil es mit über
ist nicht immer ganz einfach die meisten
youtuber haben komplett bei null
angefangen das heißt der abonnenten 0
support 0 views und es hat jahre lang
gedauert um sich das aufzubauen wo sie
jetzt gerade sind aber alle youtuber die
leute so kennt haben sich entschieden
das ding durchzuziehen und das
wichtigste was sie dabei haben ist ihr
konntet die videos diese produzieren
ohne die sind sie nix aber moment mal
die inhalte die den youtube gehören die
ihr wertvollstes gut sind wird es nicht
mehr wird sich jetzt ein fernsehsender
kommen wird und die einfach zu verwenden
würde das war doch kratzer oder wenn man
es einfach so benutzen würde im
fernsehsender den auch schon youtube
video was soll ich sagen genau so ist es
passiert wurde wird es ich hab grad die
leute verarschen nicht mehr auf twitter
richtig geschrieben so jo seppel du
warst bei dsds sieger fährt mich immer
auf der welt hätte keine ahnung schöner
wohnen sein können dies hätte werdet mir
na vielleicht nicht aber der jetzt die
es mit einer der größten shows in ganz
deutschland ich habe mir erst wieder ab
so niemals warum würde das mehr
einbinden aber dann habe ich den link
dazu bekommen und sie haben tatsächlich
gemacht bevor er weitere leute lasst uns
einfach mal reinschauen und gucken was
da passiert ist das video hier habe ich
von sps videos bekommen das ist mir viel
zu gern verlängern und ist einfach ganz
so klassisch wie jetzt erst irgend
jemand kommt rein links schlecht und
dann passiert eben das was passiert das
ist also unser kevin auch durch singen
würde
[Musik]
wir sehen schon leute er singt nicht
allzu gut und natürlich eine jury dafür
auseinander aber bei drei personen das
komplette gesetzt waren
links der frau zweite von links und von
rechts nur wird dieter bohlen ist es
passiert
es kann mit dem gesang das wäre wie wenn
du zum beispiel als teichpumpe bei mir
im garten anfangen willst oder so dann
ist das genau der richtige gesang leute
wenn ich jetzt zum ersten mal sagt mir
was eure aktion ist für kinder die jetzt
erst untersagen irgendwas von teichpumpe
und dann seht ihr meine fresse wie ich
unter wasser gurgeln und die von aktives
video kennen haben recht es ist ein
video von max ist von meinem kleinen
bruder und der szene werden gezeigt als
ich das erfahren davor ist ein ich war
ganz oft wirken oder party ist dabei
klar wahrscheinlich und die bei dir ist
er ist einfach eine anwendung für mich
wendet höchstwahrscheinlich aber es ist
wirklich so alles klar legen und da
werde ich als 100 mg größtes
gesamtzahlen in ganz deutschland nicht
aber trotzdem stehe ich jetzt als
beispiel da drinnen dafür wie beschissen
jahren singen klingen kann und deswegen
diese ansage leute das hier geht ein
dieter bohlen er hat für sendungen die
wahrscheinlich millionen leute im
fernsehen sehen ein clip in dem ich
vollkommen außen video von meinem bruder
zu keinem zeitpunkt hat uns irgendwann
erreicht hat uns angerufen oder hatte
ich irgendwie sonst bei uns gemeldet
gefragt ob man diese anwendung benutzen
da und dann werde ich auch noch so
dargestellt dass könig nur singen lieder
ich würde sagen wir klären das am besten
die männer schon bis 3 melde dich wenn
du dich traust
dr